While the R-Rated movie Logan — the third
film in the solo Wolverine franchise — isn't
set to drop until March 3, 2017, we have a
little taste of what's in store thanks to
the first trailer.
It sure seems to be inspired by Marvel’s
Old Man Logan comic series, but just how much
can we expect Logan to borrow from these pages?
Here's what you might have missed in the Logan
trailer.
No more mutants
Logan was always a reluctant member of the
X-Men, but underneath it all, he may have
needed them more than they needed him.
When we see Logan drinking alone at the cemetery,
just who is he mourning for?
"Logan.
What did you do?"
"Charles, the world is not the same as it
was.
Mutants...they're gone now."
This hints that Logan might follow at least
one major plot point of the Old Man Logan
storyline.
Believing the X-Mansion is under siege by
a group of villains, Wolverine takes them
on himself and kills them all.
It's only after they're all dead that he realizes
he's been tricked, and that he's actually
killed the X-Men.
In anguish, he gives up the Wolverine persona
and waits to die in a world mostly devoid
of superheroes.
It's obviously too soon to tell whether Logan
will follow the comics.
But in a mature movie that promises to be
emotional, gritty, and takes death seriously,
a scene depicting Wolverine's slaughter of
the X-Men would be unlike anything ever seen
in a superhero movie.
X-23
In the trailer, our hero is introduced to
a young girl who seems to have a lot in common
with Wolverine himself...
"She's like you.
Very much like you."
This is Laura Kinney, also known as X-23.
In the comics, her powers are like Wolverine's.
She has retracting claws and she can rapidly
regenerate.
So here's our question: will she be Logan’s
cloned daughter, like she is in the comics?
Or will he just feel a bond with her over
their shared abilities?
The trailer implies that Logan is forced into
action when Laura is kidnapped, which is a
complete departure from the Old Man Logan
series.
Closer to the end of the trailer, Logan has
to extend his own hand-stabbers to protect
himself against a claw-like attack.
Either Laura is demonstrating her fighting
skills to Logan to show him how they're alike…
or she’s being forced to fight him.
Those are our best guesses, at least…
Donald Pierce
The main villain of the film is a cyborg named
Donald Pierce, an anti-mutant fanatic with
a cybernetic hand.
In the comics, Pierce has a gang of fellow
cyborgs, the Reavers, and they go around hunting
down mutants.
They have a specific hatred for Wolverine,
because the Reavers became cyborgs after he
chopped off their limbs.
To be fair, most people would be at least
a little put out about that too.
"Tis but a scratch!"
"A scratch?!
Your arm's off!"
"No it isn't!"
The Reavers have been confirmed for Logan,
and it appears that they’ll act like a private
security force that works under Pierce.
It also seems like Pierce and the Reavers
have some official backing, because they use
the South American Federal Police to go after
Logan, Laura, and Charles.
Professor X
One big question about the Logan trailer is
why Pierce seems to kidnap Laura and leave
Logan alive after having him surrounded and
restrained?
This suggests there could be a much more complex
plot at the heart of Logan.
What if Pierce's real target is Charles Xavier?
In the comics, Pierce captures Charles and
tries to harness his power to hunt mutants,
so it’s possible that this will also be
a plot point in Logan.
Uncoincidentally, the mutant Caliban also
figures into Logan, who also has the power
to track other mutants.
We also see a scene showing guns pointed at
Charles' head while he’s clearly using his
mental powers as Laura crawls towards him.
What if Charles was too difficult to kidnap,
so the bad guys took Laura hostage instead?
That seems like a convoluted plot, but it
would add an emotional Sophie's Choice element
to a film in which the main character wants
to die.
Funeral for a friend
Presuming Logan did kill all the X-Men, Charles
Xavier was probably able to avoid being killed
because of his abilities.
As to why Charles didn't stop the massacre
has yet to be seen, but it appears that out
of everyone from Logan’s old life, the only
mutant, or living thing, that Logan cares
for is Charles.
At the end of the trailer, we see Wolverine
covered in blood and looking mournfully at
the ground while holding a shovel.
Logan has killed a lot of people in his day,
but he's rarely taken the time to personally
bury anyone.
You get one guess about who's taking the dirt
nap…
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
has you most excited about Logan...